hello freak [ __ ] this article I want
to talk probably got here a transgender
woman she was a woman she applied to an
all-male call female college well was
Wellesley Wellesley College ice actually
no girl from Wellesley back in the
dizzay with an all-girls campus and so
she applied for the college she was born
a female but then decided to transition
into uh she had a very hilarious this is
hilarious listen to the description of
how she introduces himself herself
whatever masculine of Center gender
queer exactly exactly yeah I am in love
with this story I am in love with these
kind of people I am in love with people
that are so [ __ ] preposterous that
they take preposterous to an art form
and they they become living parody
whether they like it or not listen to
what the [ __ ] I just said she goes to a
college he applies to an all-girls
College a super liberal all-girls
College she decides that she is
transgender and decides that she wants
to she introduces herself as masculine
of Center gender queer changes her name
to Timothy decided that she's jimothy
and asked people to use the male pronoun
when referring to him okay so welcome on
campus until the day that she announced
he announced tan Tina whatever that he
wanted to run for the school's Office of
Multicultural Affairs coordinator whose
job is to promote a cultural a culture
of diversity now who you would think
would need diversity more than someone
who's a transgender man you know I mean
that's that's a very small segment of
the population and they're often
maligned and you know this is a socially
marginalized group and it would be nice
for an open-minded liberal college to
accept someone like this and to
recognize what a perfect person to be a
part of our campaign encouraged
people to you know to be more
open-minded and accept people and know
they attacked her because now they felt
that she is a white man and they don't
want a white man in that position
because if a white man is in that
position then they're supporting the
patriarchy so there was three other
candidates for the gig right all women
of color wonderful if one of them went
and then you got okay you know your
problem solved you got a woman of color
in that position plenty of diversity
there you're good right and no they all
dropped out and then they stayed it they
started an anonymous Facebook campaign
encouraging people not to vote at all to
keep a white man from winning the
position ah this is amazing this is the
left eating itself that's what's
happening they're eating themselves
it is a feeding frenzy I stab piranhas
okay and one of the things about
products is well one gets a limp
they just Jack that [ __ ] they
are the most ruthless [ __ ] when one
piranha would just speak you know
sometimes you have a fish tank one fish
will just start swimming weird they
start swimming kind of half sideways for
some reason like is that fish okay and
you have to look at them like what's
going on with that fish that [ __ ] didn't
last in that tank baby no those
[ __ ] are just art taking chunks
out of them that's what's happening here
the left is they're turning on
themselves they've run out of outrage
they've made so many safe places they
don't want anything to be safe anymore
and they want to be able to go to war
over everything they're ferocious
they're piranhas they are social idea
piranhas and they're attacking a
genderqueer
genderqueer masculine of Center man for
not being diverse enough for being a
part of the patriarchy bar no woman born
a woman lived as a woman no you're a
white man now you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you're a part of the problem it does
make sense though
it makes sense because it highlights
what this movement is all about its
socially [ __ ] people that are left
loan to their own devices and they're
just devouring each other like zombies
they're just tearing into each other
like like zombies that are trapped into
a [ __ ] room it is right it is ripping
each other apart
you're not diverse enough you're not
progressive enough [ __ ] you you're such
a pig I'm triggered they just trigger
each other left and right this is this
is an onion article this is a [ __ ]
onion article and it's not this is a
national review this is a goddamn onion
article and it's not transgender woman
can't be diversity officer because she's
a white man now ha ha ha ha ha ha
mixture offense it's all it's all the
sense in the world that it's not a fake
article I mean that regime herb that
kind of percent of figures are perfect
it's perfect it's amazing it's beautiful
it's a rose it's a rose in a bad
neighborhood pops out of the concrete
and it comes out perfect it's amazing
this is art it's the universe creating
art with our own folly that's what it is
it's culture it's called it's it's
people you know there's something that
happens to people when you deny reality
when you don't look at things
objectively like this I think like
priests that molest kids right some of
that has to be from suppression some of
it has to be probably their abuse
themselves is probably all sorts of but
some of that perversion has got to come
from suppression it's like the Catholic
schoolgirl thing that everybody knows
you know when I was in high school there
was no scientists in my [ __ ] ninth
grade class but we all knew that girls
went to Catholic schools were hoes and
why they host their hoes because
everybody tells them they can't be a ho
everybody's talked to them constantly
about you are going to go to hell
do not touch a man's genitals don't you
do anything else cause we're freaks they
were the biggest freaks and we all knew
it it was it was there was no books on
it there was no YouTube videos that we
could watch but we [ __ ] knew it man
we all knew it and I think it's a
suppression issue and this is
suppressing individual identity this is
suppressing free speech
this is suppressing objectivity you're
not allowed to have
unique or intertwined thoughts you're
not allowed to share opinions with the
left and with the right you're not
allowed to you have to have and you're
constantly worried about being called
out you're constantly worried about
being outed and doxxed and called out
and shamed everyone's shaming people and
attacking people and it's this [ __ ]
feeding frenzy I love it I'm happy I'm
so happy when I read a story like this I
would encourage this woman to fight to
the death for her position oh man she's
a man now fight to the death to that
position I mean literally I want you to
show up for school in a [ __ ] armor
with a sword and let them know that you
or you are here you are a warrior for
diversity and you're going to give it
you're going to take this to the very
end to the very end of time oh it's
amazing this is an amazing story took
one of the greatest stories the the
universe has ever told because it's it
just and it highlights that story that
we were just talking about where the
thing that was up on the other thing
earlier with the the United States is
like a powder keg that this is like what
we're talking about like entitled
ridiculous people that they don't live
in reality
you're you're not live and you're
concentrating on nonsense
but why they concentrating on nonsense
because they don't have to worry about
feeding themselves they don't have to
worry about shelter they don't have to
worry about being in Ohio
having no [ __ ] power for a week and
everybody has to stay alive you can't
get to work everybody's like walking
back and forth to each other's house
sharing food and going out and getting
firewood together and dragging it back
and some little kids wagon that's what
people do when they want to survive when
when you want to survive you come up
with ways that you can all work together
when it's too easy to survive you start
attacking people for nonsense and that's
the [ __ ] is going on here
you got a campaign to keep through we're
going to make sure that a white man's
not going to win this like is if she's
really a white man why are we pretending
that's a man left of queer genderqueer
masculine of Center shut the [ __ ] up
your girl you're a girl or a guy
whatever you are who cares what the [ __ ]
sorry
more to the story she's just a big [ __ ]
you know like she's just got been god we
just eaten too much [ __ ] on campus
they're all mad yeah it should feel good
at it he's too good at it but she's
genderqueer so that means I don't think
he'd do anything I don't know what that
means
I think they know what it means well you
ever pansexual there was a woman who was
like she was making history this is
hilarious this is a hilarious story
she's making history because she was the
first gender she was the first pansexual
person to take office what the [ __ ] are
you talking about what does that mean I
mean she doesn't sexually identify
particularly sexually attracted to
either race or either gender it's either
one or both Miley Cyrus is pansexual
course she is that's called being a
freak
pansexual what exactly does that mean
but go find the politician first
politician as pansexual it's just so
stupid Penn sexual politician since like
a new word for bisexual it's not even
bisexual it's because like they have to
be special and it has to be Mary
Gonzales Texas State Representative
identifies as pansexual in new interview
first of all good for her eat that [ __ ]
suck that dick have a party honey I'm
not hating do whatever you want but do
we really have to make a new name for it
[ __ ] Christ
and I posted something about this a
while back on Twitter and there was
people that were defending the term ped
sexual I'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you for
trying to muddy up the world [ __ ] you
for having this on your mind unless
you're mocking it [ __ ] you for taking
this seriously [ __ ] you for this being
an actual thing we want to debate it how
bad is your job how bored you at work
you're sitting in front of your Twitter
account defending pansexuality you stop
you stop I'm sick she could do it I have
no problems here Nona don't get me wrong
but you [ __ ] stop if you think you're
going to defend that
[ __ ] you you need to go cuts no cuts no
need to go to countries need to go cut
trees and shovel snow over Jamie's
parents house and
the winter when the [ __ ] powers off
for a month that's what you need to do
you need a dig Brian red bands mom out
of the [ __ ] woods digger out of the
woods some mild dirt road back to that
lady's house get Det go on [ __ ]
that's like what is that how many
thousand pieces Amaro five thousand five
thousand plus feet of snow shoveling you
[ __ ] how much for the driveway remember
that you remember that when you're a kid
you go to lady's house and you go ma'am
we're we're shoveling stuff well how
much for the driveway only gonna need 20
for this one that's too much that's too
much the long driveway man was going to
take us a couple hours oh that's just
too much don't get mad
[Music]